[Music]
one everyday item uniquely captures
Queen Elizabeth's 70 years on the throne
money
there are currently 4.7 billion
banknotes and 29 billion coins in
circulation in the UK with the Queen's
face front and center the image is
almost like a logo announcement of the
UK and the state but now as Charles
takes the Reign currency along with
several other items stand to change
basically the biggest things is probably
going to be the currency which will take
quite a number of years here's why
updating money may be a longer process
than some of the other items that bear
her name
after seven decades the Queen's presence
is deeply ingrained in the UK seen
tangibly on stamps and post boxes even
on cookie and gin labels
some things like the national anthem
have already been updated
[Music]
but currency is a longer process as the
previous precedent shows coins for the
new reign will shortly be turned out in
quantity at the Royal Mint let's hope
you'll soon get some Elizabeth became
Queen in 1952 with her coronation the
following year coins in the UK began
showing Elizabeth's portrait in 1953.
according to the Royal Mint the nation's
coin supplier but it wasn't until 1956
that the bank of England received
permission from the UK treasury to use
the Queen's portrait on a banknote and
it was another four years before the
public saw the first note in hand while
there's a long history of monarchs
featured on coins this made her the
first British royal to have a photo
featured on paper bills in historic
England one of the only ways that some
of the commoners would even know what
the Monarch looked like was was by
having it on a coin since Elizabeth's
first note the bank has revised it
several times times adding new security
features and updating the Queen's image
most recently in an effort to extend the
lifespan of its currency the bank began
printing polymer notes rather than paper
ones that transition began in 2016 and
will be complete by the end of September
this year
meanwhile the latest coin in the UK was
unveiled in 2015. the Royal Mint worked
with the queen on five portraits with
the latest created by artist Jody Clark
quite a lot of departments have touched
the project so once I finished with it
it'll go on to production and we not
only do the drawing real sleep we sculpt
the low release sculpture which is on
the coin as well which is going to stamp
out all the coins a separate version of
his design began appearing on Australian
coins in 2019. the effigy on Australian
coins is called the Commonwealth Effigy
it's actually a different portrait
altogether and Commonwealth country uh
could use that portrait but the UK one
is exclusively before the UK Australia
is just one of many commonwealth
countries whose currency Bears the
Queen's image but that doesn't guarantee
Charles will take her place on those
currencies does Canada does Australia
does New Zealand does Belize still feel
a need or or interest in in putting the
k on its currency does it want to update
the queen most of Canada's currency has
phased out the queen for instance but
they do leave her on the 20. Andrew Lee
Australia's assistant prime minister for
treasury reiterated this point in a
recent press conference as I understand
it the decision to include the Queen's
face and the five dollar note was about
her personally rather than about her
status as a monarch so that transition
isn't automatic the Royal Australian men
said that coins featuring The Queen will
remain legal currency but they will not
release any new ones with her image in
2023 still with 15 billion coins
featuring The Queen in circulation and
only 110 million new coins minted a year
in Australia coins featuring The Queen
will remain in circulation for many
years to come other commonwealth
countries have said they plan to
continue using the queen's image like
The Reserve Bank in New Zealand and the
Bank of Canada the bank of England
hasn't given any insight into its
timeline for note featuring Charles but
it assured the public that current notes
featuring The Queen will continue to be
legal tender the royal men already
offers coins that feature King Charles
on its website though these coins were
made for his birthdays and are not in
circulation as for how Charles portrait
may look some have said that he will
face left since the queen faced right
the short answer is tradition because
you alternate sides apparently here in
terms of which way the Monarch is facing
on the currency
more details are expected from the bank
of England following the 10-day morning
period
[Music]